NOT GOING TO BE A SUPER LONG
MEETINGS- THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SUSPENSE FILE HEARING
FOR THE TWO YEAR- HOUSE OF
ORIGIN BILLS- THERE THIRTEEN
BILLS WILL BE CALLING- ROLL
CALL ON EACH MEMBER OF THE WITH
ASKING. MEMBERS TO MAKE A
MOTION THAT WILL DEAL ROLL
CALL- JUST A REMINDER THAT
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THESE- MEASURES WHEN
THEY HAD THEIR- ORIGINALLY
HEARING SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE OPENING UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE
THROUGH DISPENSED FIVE A LET'S
DO A ROLL CALL THOSE THAT WAS
REQUIRED. PORTANTINO I'M HERE
PORTANTINO HERE FAITH HI BABY
HERE FROM BATES HERE BRADFORD
BRADFORD HERE DORADO DORADO
HERE HELL. HELL HERE JONES.
JONES HERE WHY CASKEY MY CASKEY
HERE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
ACQUIRED WE'RE GONNA START TO
OUR FIRST BILL- IS MISTER OUR
MISTER ALLEN'S BILLS SB FORTY
FIVE THE RECOMMENDATION IS A
MAN FOR AUTHOR TO INCREASE THE
OVERALL BOTTOM OUT AND CHANGE
SPECIFIED ALLOCATIONS IS THERE
A MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION
SEEING NO QUESTIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. YES YES AS IN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. ROBERT
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES. JONES NO
AYE CASKEY HI MY COUNTY I. THE
BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO ONE WE
HAVE EVERYBODY HERE AND WE HAD
ONE EXCEPTION SO WHAT. THERE
WAS A. BUT IT'S NOT I CALL
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS HERE OKAY
SB SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ON STATE
HIGHWAYS THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS THE FOR A MINUTE WITH
AMENDMENTS FOR AUTHOR TO
REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO
RELINQUISH PORTION OF THE SEVEN
TEN FREEWAY IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA EMOTION SO MOVED. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER WHITE
CASKEY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES
NO BRADFORD. BRADFORD I'D RAZA.
DORADO AYE HILL. HILL AYE
JONES. JONES I WHITE HOUSE GUY
MY CASKEY I. SIX TO ONE THAT
PASSES SIX TO ONE WILL MOVE ON
TO MISTER BRADFORD SCR SIXTY
NINE MOTION IS TO PASS IT TO
THE FLOOR WITH AMENDMENTS FOR
AUTHOR TO CHANGE THE TERMS AND
UPDATE THE INFORMATION. SIR
MOTION SO MOVE HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR WITH AMENDMENTS
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D
RAZA DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES I'VE AYE CASKEY HI
MY CASKEY I. SIX THAT BILL WAS
OUT SIX ZERO WILL MOVE ON TO
MISS CHIANG SB SIX FIFTY THREE-
THE MOTION IS- TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR WITH AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHOR TO REMOVE PREVENTION
RELATED TO A FORMER DENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE
AREAS AND MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
CHANGES IS OUR MOTION THE BILL.
ALAMO MISTER THIS CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO. I PORTANTINO AYE
BATES RIGHT BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD I'D RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES RIGHT JONES
I WORK OWSKI MAKOWSKI AYE SEVEN
FOR THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO
WILL MOVE ON THE MOST GALGIANI
SB THREE EIGHT EIGHT THAT IS A
DISASTER RECOMMENDATION FOR
MOTION SO MOVED A MOTION BY
MISTER CASKEY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PORTANTINO I KNOW I
BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE TO RUSSELL RUSSELL
AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES I
WAY CASKEY MAKOWSKI I. THE BILL
IS OUT SEVEN TO ZERO WELL
MOVING ON TO MISTER HERTZBERG
SP TWO FIVE FOUR ON THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION IS THERE A
MOTION. SOME OF OCEAN BY MISTER
WHITE CASKEY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D RAZA DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES I
WAKE HUSKY HI MY CASKEY I. THE
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING
ON TO MISS SKINNER SB THIRTY
THREE- THE TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION IS OUR MOTION SO
MOVED. I HAVE A MOTION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AND YOU KNOW I
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES I Y. CASKEY MAKOWSKI I.
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO
MOVING TO MR STERN SB FIVE
NINETY SIX I. H. S. S. THAT MY
THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
MOTION IS TO MOVE TO THE FLOOR
WITH AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW USE OF
EXISTING MATERIALS AN APPLICANT
NOTIFICATION. OUR MOTION SO
MOVED. HAVE A MOTION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FOR PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES. BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D RAZA. ROSS SO I
HILL. HILL AYE JONES JONES I Y.
CASKEY MAKOWSKI I. THE BILL IS
OUT SEVEN ZERO SB SEVEN THIRTY
NINE ON FIRE PREVENTION
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND HOME
HARDENING TRAINING
RECOMMENDATION OR THE MOTION IS
TO DO PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR PLEASE GIVE ME MOTION.
SOME OF I'M SORRY SENATE FOR.
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER WHITE
KOWSKI PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YOU KNOW I PORTANTINO BATES.
ALL RIGHT FACE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA. DORADO
AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES. JONES
I Y. CASKEY MAKOWSKI I. THE
BILL WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING
ON TO MR UMBER GUESS BE FORTY
FOUR ON UC PILOT PROJECT
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE FOR
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS. WE
HAVE A MOTION TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO
AYE BATES AYE BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE TO RAZA.
RUSSELL AYE HILL PHIL I JONES.
JONES I WIECKOWSKI HI MY CASKEY
I. THE BILL OUT SEVEN ZERO ON
THE MISTER WHITE SKI. THREE
SEVENTY TWO IT IS- MOVED TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR WITH AMENDMENTS
TO ENSURE I'M SORRY SENATE WHY
DON'T YOU SING ASSEMBLY. HAVING
PTSD I GUESS SO- MEMBERS TO
ENSURE CURBSIDE RECYCLING IS
NOT ADVERSELY AFFECTED SO MOVED
TO. WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
WHITE CASKEY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OKAY. EXACTLY WHAT DIE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HEY PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD
AYE TO RAZA DORADO AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO WHITE
HOUSE KING HI MY CASKEY I. TWO
ONE FIVE TWO ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT. MOVING ON TO MISTER WEINER
SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THE
ENERGY IS IT HE ENTERED HIS
ATION EVENTS REPORTS IS A DO
PASS RIGHT- MOTION SIR MOTIONS
SOME OF. THE MOTION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. BATES NO
BRADFORD. THE RAZA. TRUST DRAWS
ARE AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WHITE HOUSE KING. I
KELSEY I. THE BILL IS OUT FORTY
TWO WE HAVE ONE OF THE LAST
BILL- IS WEBER AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY THE DO PASS MOTION IS OUR
MOTION SOME OF THE MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES NO
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D
RAZA FOR US SO I HILL HILL AYE
JONES. JOHN NO WAY CASKEY HIGH
ACCOUNTS I. THAT BILLS OUT FIVE
TO- THAT CONCLUDES OUR SUSPENSE
FILE THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
TODAY AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE WE ARE TURN.